arriving at a Cypriot quarter British
woman who says she was gang-raped by 12
Israeli tourists and yet today she was
the one on trial convicted of the crime
of public mischief effectively found
guilty of fabricating a horrendous
atomic the decision of their Court is
respected however we respectfully
disagree with it we believe that there
have been many violations in the
procedure and the rights of fair trial
of a client have been violated we are
planning to appeal the decision to the
Supreme Court hoping that our client
will find justice in Cyprus the woman
who comes from Derbyshire and Compton
named was on a working holiday at the
resort of Ayia Napa in July she says she
was repeatedly assaulted by the group
police arrested the tourists but then
the woman signed a statement retracting
her accusation the men were allowed to
go home but during the trial she told
the court she had been raped that it was
the Cypriot police who pushed her to
retract those claims that was a
suggestion the judge dismissed saying
the woman was simply ashamed outside the
court protesters offered support who
claimed that violence against women is
routinely ignored in Cyprus we disagree
with the judgement that's why we are
here in support of the young British
lady who instead of being their
complainant to their father rape she has
been converted into an accused person a
forensic pathologist said the woman had
suffered injuries consistent with rape
today the lawyer representing the
Israeli Church though sounded almost
euphoric I hope the court will impose a
whole punishment to reflect the damage
done to my client I glad to hear that
the court convinced ago and
I very very happy the British government
has said this is a deeply distressing
case and said it was supporting the
woman and her family she is said to be
traumatized and has already lodged an
appeal against her conviction
Adam Parsons Sky News